monsieur bonsoir fin du projet de loi
devaquet aujourd'hui à 13 heures pour
être précis des manifestations ont eu
lieu dans toute la région à la mémoire
des coûts cecchin étudiants mort samedi
dernier à paris à vesoul en haute-saône
ce matin 600 lycéens ont effectué une
marche silencieuse cet après midi 200
élèves du lep luxembourg déposé une
gerbe alors que 450 lycéens degré et
luxeuil défilé dans les rues et à
besançon les mêmes manifestations ont eu
lieu dans le calme et la dignité
la voix de jacques chirac dans les haut
parleurs de la fac de lettres a appris
aux étudiants le retrait du projet de
loi devaquet les applaudissements ont
salué cette déclaration mais pas
d'explosion de joie la mort de malick sy
qui pèse encore très fort sur le coeur
de l'étudiant
one forte une forte joie mais enfin
beaucoup d'amis qui parce que je trouve
que ce n'est pas très normal d'en être
arrivé là et qu'il a fait lui qui en
mars pour que le gouvernement chirac
chrétienne au projet de vérifier à 16
heures la place saint-pierre est noire
de monde à la mémoire de manipuler film
le silence sera le seul mot d'ordre
pourtant dans la foule on commence déjà
à tirer des bilans le mouvement il
aurait pu devenir une autre façon de
faire de la politique car en france
justement sans pour autant être dans à
partir de lundi
et montrer que des gens qui ont des
choses à dire et qui peuvent qui peuvent
agir
à 16h15 le cortège s'ébranle toujours
dans le silence
les étudiants les lycéens sont
maintenant confrontés à l'avenir délicat
de ceux qui viennent de remporter une
victoire leur nombre aujourd'hui encore
leproux le soulagement se mélange à
l'anxiété que va devenir le mouvement
pourront-ils se faire entendre à
l'occasion de la consultation nationale
promise par le gouvernement
plus directement personne ne sait
actuellement si la grève et la
manifestation de mercredi seront
maintenus ou subtile
et au delà des prospectives et des
suppositions reste la tristesse de lutte
depuis trois jours a dépassé les
étudiants la violence il ne l'avait pas
voulu le cortège cet après-midi enterrer
les illusions d'une jeunesse pleine de
générosité
à la préfecture ce soir veut ni un
silence hurlant de dépit et d'amertume
une manifestation impressionnante de
dignité que l'on soutienne non leur
mouvement
une chose est sûre ce soir une partie de
la jeunesse française est entrée en
politique dans le sens noble du terme
puis la manifestation qui doit avoir
lieu mercredi prochain au niveau
national est maintenu